foreign
was the last time you thought about your
first time hey I'm Alyssa and today I
brought in four women who are going to
be doing cold calls the guys they lost
their virginity to we have no idea if
they're gonna pick up we're a little bit
nervous we're a little bit scared we're
a little excited hello welcome okay we
did not plan this yes thanks so much for
coming thanks for having me yeah tell us
a little bit about the person that you
lost your virginity to I lost my
virginity to my boyfriend my high school
sweetheart
um we ended up dating for five years and
wow okay so this guy I met him literally
10 years ago oh wow yes at a Halloween
party which is like super cliche so I
met him my senior year of high school
okay before I even dated anything we
um were just hanging out in his friend's
sister's room so Random they're gonna
hang out and we talked for like six plus
hours he opened up to me I opened up to
him which is weird because we didn't
know each other like that yeah that's
when like it all happened like that's
when we were like okay maybe we could
take this a step further uh have you
ever heard of Omegle it's like a video
chat thing where it's like random people
come up yeah him and my best friend were
talking falls in love with him oh it's
like you're gonna love this dude Bella
wait also is this is this normal is this
how people are meeting should I get on
Omegle this is how I remember it I would
love to know how he remembers it because
right so that's part of why you want to
call him yeah and like I'm fill in the
gaps exactly okay well I think we're
ready to give him a call if you are yeah
yeah that's true I'm excited to see I
hope he answers he feels so nervous I'm
nervous
I literally
hey
[Music]
this is Ava I don't know if you remember
me
um we met 10 years ago Halloween night
dude you were dressed as man bear pig I
don't know if you remember this it was a
dope costume
that sounds sounds like something yeah
you definitely did that you know I'd
love to know what you remember about it
because I feel like you know my memory
is not the best
yeah just a bit uh
okay this is it
okay
oh okay yes no I remember that now yeah
there was some something playing in the
background probably I don't know if you
remember we slept together and you asked
me you asked me at the time if you know
this was my first time but I basically
lied to you and I was like no this is
not my first time because I wanted to
say face in front of you I don't know
but I'm calling you to tell you I have
positive memories I really do it was it
was positive experience I really hope so
it was it was
I can't get to the phone right now
please leave a message
hey um it's my Lynn I was just kind of
calling I wanted to see how you were
doing
um maybe we can like catch up and talk
about everything because I haven't heard
from you in a long time but yeah I hope
you're doing well and hopefully you can
get back to me
goes good very half my number he I think
he just declined it because he saw it
really yes oh my God
how are you
[Music]
here
oh really why do you say so
has it been seven that's not true
let me do the math okay I guess so sure
yeah what did it end we continued dating
for I would say a month or something oh
okay very short time period you know
when you just stop liking them yeah you
get thick yeah I feel bad because it was
really out of the blue for him he was so
shook he started dating for a year and a
half to my sophomore year I joined the
cheer team that's when everything kind
of went downhill because I started
hanging out with like my teammates and
other athletes and he was just not
having it like I'm your best friend like
you need to be with me and stuff like
that yeah but it got to a point where I
just like why am I staying with someone
that's holding me back from all these
experiences yeah I was like okay
um let's take a break and our rule was
like if we take a break we're going to
break up um I actually got with someone
else at the time sure because I thought
we were done it was a one day break I
guess he said it was one day break so
one day break so he was like did you do
anything on our break and I was like no
like you know what are you talking about
no I didn't do anything but yeah
[Laughter]
I'm good I'm honestly I'm doing great
still trying to date still trying to
figure out my life
um but everything's been good
everything's been awesome how are you
how's life for you
when okay I've got a girlfriend I've
been with for about six months oh wow oh
good
I'm curious I'm curious do you remember
anything
you're sorry it is
a little bit of
I'm trying to remember it no that's okay
I you know what I should have just given
you a picture of that night
um
I do I I straight up do do you want me
to send it to you okay okay oh my God
yeah I don't remember yeah
[Laughter]
just the haunting you ten years later
but you ever expect me to call you
really
well you remember when I called you the
last time
no what yes you do we had such a long
conversation
oh my gosh all right all right and so
you guys haven't really spoken since we
spoke one time I had just broken up with
my second boyfriend and I thought what's
the harm in calling the first one we had
a really nice four-hour conversation
which ended with uh him kind of trying
to booty call me so I wasn't about it
for some reason I just wanted him to
kind of be nice and caring in that
moment instead he was kind of like yeah
and then so then that was the last time
you guys spoke yeah since I have you
here and we're on the topic
um
I know when we first dated for the first
time we were like pretty peachy like we
would like hold hands in the hallway and
like cuddle but like you know nothing
really happened
um and I remember experiencing
um
sexual assault I think we were together
for the first time
um
and I remember like
feeling really scared and just like
uncomfortable and really not knowing
what to do
um and I remember like the only person I
felt comfortable telling it about was
you
um and I just wanted to say that like I
really really appreciate you know our
relationship and the time we spent
together and like how like gracious you
were with me and like how patient you
were with me because you know there were
a lot of things I wasn't willing to do
and things that I just felt
uncomfortable with because of my past
experiences
um and I feel like I never like really
got to articulate that to you that like
that's like so meaningful that like I
can look back on like my first time in
like my first real relationship and like
look at it so positively and just know
that like I healed so much during those
years because of how amazing you were
and like how special our relationship
was and like yeah I just I just wanted
to say that because I feel like I've
maybe expressed it
um in subtle ways but I just wanted to
like fully put it on the table and just
like say thank you for that it was
really meaningful to me so yeah yeah
this
means a lot to me
that we could
still
children
you know even though we're not together
like I still really really care for you
and like really look on those times
fondly and I hope that you do too
yeah I do
yeah thank you
um
yeah yeah thank you I do remember like
just feeling really comfortable even
after the experience that I had I you
know for you I don't know how like
significant it was but because it was
quite significant for me so you set a
really positive tone for me I'm so happy
to hear that because I've only been with
my high school girlfriend until like
2012. oh wow and then I mean I ended up
joining
for my junior year yeah and then I kind
of started
using track but like
because I to be honest I didn't tell you
the truth because I was like oh he's so
experienced like I need to be able to
save this I had no idea that I was like
among the first for you so that also
makes me feel really good it's two three
months past and he's getting to a point
where he's like calling me 24 7 like
looking at my location oh no if I would
be sleeping and I don't answer my phone
he would call my friends like stuff like
that like yeah so I was like you know
what I think I'm done I gave him his
promise ring so I had a promise ring so
that in my mind we're done and I get
with a different person and I don't know
how somehow someone he found out he was
like calling me he was coming to my dorm
he's like I'm getting all my stuff back
I I heard what you did I called your mom
he called my mom I get to my dorm and
he's like taking us like pulling his
stuff ripping out he's already in your
room yeah how did he get in called my
roommate and he's like how does he have
all these numbers the last thing you
ever said to me and I remember this so
distinctly I'm like like what are you
doing like what like you know what
happened he's like I know you slept with
two athletes and I like me and my best
friend look at each other speechless and
then he just drives off and like that's
the last thing I ever heard from him oh
my gosh yeah I can't find you on social
media what's going on with that
oh
okay all right
um
[Music]
oh okay all right well call me if you
ever
um
if you ever feel like it you know doors
open
all right bye
what's going on I'm a pretty private guy
yeah
no problem yeah
[Music]
thank you so much for answering and just
being so cool about this
yeah of course cool well I'll talk to
you later at some point
okay cool bye
that's literally as good as it possibly
could have gone amazing I really
appreciate you talking about this I know
it can it's awkward to talk about and
like we went through a lot together and
I'm I'm honestly just really glad that I
went through it with you
okay
it means a lot I love you
okay I'll talk to you later
okay bye
oh my gosh how does that make you feel
oh it feels like a really yeah it felt
really good I'm like rooting for you
guys
did you feel like maybe he was like oh
and I have a girlfriend like did you
because maybe I feel like maybe there
was like a part of him that was like oh
are you trying to like get back together
oh my God I don't know why but I was
like I'm still dating
and honestly it just shows his character
like he's a he's a good guy up front
like got a girlfriend but like you know
we can hang out and of course yeah lunch
or whatever is there kind of like
something you would want to say yeah
okay I've thought about this for I
thought about this for a long time for
literally the past two years I would
want to say like thank you honestly like
thank you because from that like
relationship I learned so much going
forward yeah I learned how I should be
treated and I don't want to make him
feel like a bad guy because we did have
like you know our good times of course
but it's just like I don't want anyone
to ever be like you have to do what I
say and you gotta tell me what to do
what to wear who to hang out with like
yeah going forward like it's kind of
like my self-worth I know more for
myself and I want more for myself I'll
be honest with you I feel quite uneasy I
just feel just for so long I had like
such good memories of it remembering
that he is a stand-up guy and he's warm
and that's the reason I felt so
comfortable in the first place and maybe
on all of that can still be true I think
that is do you know what I mean like all
of that is how you felt in those moments
I think this having an awkward phone
call now I don't think that should like
take away from like those real memories
that you had when you were with them you
know yeah yeah you're right I'm glad you
guys found each other it was really
sweet and special just two people who
really connect and like will always be
in each other's lives you know even if
that relationship changes over time you
know oh absolutely and that you know I
know that's not everybody's story and
everybody I mean me
like that like nice relationship with
some of my exes and it does make me sad
especially like my first love I feel
like you know I would love it if we
could still but it just didn't work out
that way yeah I feel like that healed me
like that oh
you know he's still in love with you
oh my gosh that was incredible
so curious to hear what you guys thought
comment if you think you might do this
and what that phone call would look like
I'm definitely going to be making a
couple phone calls after this just
kidding I don't have a first time just
kidding I do comment below if you think
I'm a virgin
[Laughter]